hey sorry has officially sold out what's
next Wally on ice video games tell me to
do things all the time and I just do
them introducing the window a new web
series from wired there's a video of me
getting my Super NES and screaming I
have the power get to the bottom of your
cup of coffee what's inside travel
inside a strike-anywhere match to
uncover the chemistry video game stories
have been just been getting better and
better and better skimpy 169 minutes of
running time devoted to the entire first
six chapters of the book on forgivable
I've been a fight I tab and discover the
secret Perkins dulu fighting on the sky
platform and following hundreds of miles
to a planet's surface um